the FCC has increasingly become a force
for evil under the Trump administration
not the least of which is because of
their opposition to net neutrality
regulations which as you know from the
Obama era have been repealed by Trump's
FCC and the big news this week this is a
major story and it's not getting as much
coverage as it should
partially because some people don't
recognize how big it is partially
because there were like 10 other
scandals in the last 48 hours the big
news is that the FCC has admitted this
week it wasn't actually hacked you might
remember that back during the public
comment period around the net neutrality
repeal the FCC said we are going to have
a period of I don't remember how many
weeks it was during which people can
write in and they can tell us we want
you to repeal net neutrality or we don't
want you to repeal net neutrality and
the FCC claimed that a DDoS attack a
denial of service attack a hack took
down the public comment system and as a
result the system went down right we got
hacked the system went down we can't
take public comments sorry
however former Verizon lawyer and
current FCC Chairman Ajit PI has now
admitted there was no hack it simply
wasn't true and here's the just absolute
goldmine Ajit PI is blaming the Obama
administration because even though the
lie was made during the Trump
administration and by the Trump FCC
while trying to repeal Obama era net
neutrality regulations Ajit PI says that
the Trump FCC inherited a culture from
the Obama administration which led to
the lying so listen it's basically Obama
so Obama might as well have been
personally lying as far as Ajit PI is
concerned here thanks Obama
he did it again what happened to
personal responsibility what happened to
the buck stops with the person at the
top and the FCC and a GP I have been
repeating this lie for a year or more at
this point that a hack took down the
comment system so tons of people who
wanted to comment about the net
neutrality repeal couldn't and it just
wasn't true the FCC Inspector General
investigated found that the claim of a
hack was a total lie and a
course the real reason that the system
went down there's sort of two
possibilities one is much worse than the
other okay
possibility one is that so many millions
of Americans were against the net
neutrality repeal that they wanted to
make their voices heard period and that
led to so much traffic that the comments
section went down on the FCC's website
that's like the less sinister
explanation the more sinister
explanation is that the FCC took down
the comments section to prevent those
comments from being made in the first
place and we don't know which one it is
as far as the so-called apology goes
this could be one of the most bogus
apologies we've heard recently I
apologize for the fact that an Obama
person lied the follow-up
part of this is whether a Jeep I knew he
was lying all along a Jeep PI's saying
that's a conspiracy theory he included
in his statement about this the
following quote I'm pleased that this
report debunks the conspiracy theory
that my officer I had any knowledge that
the information provided by the former
CIO was inaccurate and was allowing that
inaccurate information to be
disseminated for political purposes
we'll see whether that's a conspiracy
theory it's kind of hard for me to
believe that Ajit PI and the higher-ups
at the FCC were told this is a hack they
had a ton of data to review related to
whether it was a hack they looked at the
data presumably and they still came away
thinking it was a hack when there was no
actual evidence that they got hacked I
don't know that I believe that Ajit pie
wasn't just parroting something he knew
wasn't true yeah signs show I think that
this was taken down deliberately and
then you'd have to hold the GDI
accountable for that and just it goes to
this bigger picture that even though
it's the FCC and they're the government
they're supposed to be working for the
people they don't really care what you
have to say if you disagree with them
they'll take you down they'll shut you
down they just want to listen to the
corporate interests that's the bummer at
the bottom line which is we're sort of
debating over what was the reason why
people against repealing net neutrality
weren't able to make the comments the
truth is that even if they were able to
make the comments it was getting
repealed either way right like
the FCC never cared what public opinion
was they and Ajit PI are tools of the
NCTA the cable lobby and the ISPs and
everybody else who has a financial
interest in repealing that neutrality
and it's silly to even pretend like oh
you know if they had just gotten 500,000
or a million more comments against the
repeal they wouldn't have repealed it of
course not they were repealing it no
matter what and I I will actually want
to take it a step further this is
something that is resignation worthy in
my mind when we talk about creeping
authoritarianism and the authoritarian
slide under the Trump administration
it's really scary to realize that a
federal agency can lie to everybody
about what happened possibly knowingly
use that lie to say that they or to
defect effectively ignore the opposition
to what they're doing which is the
killing of net neutrality they later
admit that it was a lie but they get to
keep the repeal as if the lie is
irrelevant and the truth is that in the
end the lie is irrelevant because the
comments were going to be irrelevant and
a GP I should be fired the bucks should
stop with him personal responsibility
he's in charge blaming the culture of
the Obama administration for this is a
joke and at worst they took down the
comment section which is a form of if
they did it deliberately government
limiting free expression well a GP I
could in theory be impeached by the
Senate the only problem is those
senators are also bought and paid for by
the telecom companies I would not hold
my breath for even 10 seconds hoping
that the Republican Senate is going to
punish Ajit PI for lying that is I mean
it's I it's inconceivable that that
would take place so are you surprised
about this not really
are we dismayed by it we are but it is
just yet another instance of this
decided and definitive creep towards
authoritarianism and a government that
eliminates checks and balances ignores
the will of the people and this is what
we've got to look forward to if
Democrats don't take over the House and
Senate in 2018 and
certainly if Donald Trump is reelected
in 2020 it is going to continue creeping
to the point where we might call it
what's the next thing after creeping
walking I don't know I think it's there
it's there you're just a Thorat Arianism
will eventually get there that's exactly
right
discuss this with us on the david pakman
show subreddit david pakman.com slash re
d di t and if you're not following the
show on instagram at david pakman show
please do I will be answering questions
there after today's show submit your
question at david pakman show on
instagram today's program brought to you
in part by Blink accom / Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book PS jobs by David
Graeber which I listen to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm / Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be Li NK
is t.com /pa que mas